every year there are roughly 10 000  unsolved murders in America  sometimes it's the victims who helped  solve the crime  [Music]  seeing how he was left in that moment  that's the hard part  her social media accounts went dead  immediate red flag  she had 10 000 followers  fitness app to count her steps you can  see the Panic the phone is moving all  over  front page this is huge this is a  blockbuster story  social media was a wave to say here's a  little morsel to follow up on  [Music]  cell tower data showed the location  where the body was found  the police came across the diary she  named two guys she was able to tell the  police what happened the victims of  their intervention stopped their killers  guilty guilty on all of the counts  their words crying out from the dark  finding Justice for themselves they  solved in their own murder from Beyond  the Grave  [Music]